حديقه المنزل هذه شهدت جريمه مروعه عندما
فتح جار هولندي النار على عائله بريطانيه
في فرنسا فقتل طفله عمرها 11 عاما واصاب
والدها بجراح خطيره اما الابنه الصغرى ذات
ثمانيه اعوام فدخلت في حاله صدمه الى جانب
الام الثكله المصابه بجراح متوسطه
السلطات الفرنسيه قالت ان الجارين كان
بينهما خلاف قديم على قطعه ارض مجاوره
لمنزليهما يرجح انها السبب في وصول الخلاف
الى حد اطلاق النار من الجار المتقاعد لل
71 عاما الذي باغت العائله بعده طلقات
ناريه قبل ان ينسحب وزوجته من المكان
اللحظات الاخيره للعائله المكلومه يرويها
جار اخر حيث قال ان الام والاب كانايعدان
الشواء بينما كانت الطفلتان تلهوان حولهما
في حديقه منزلهما الكائن في بلده بلونيفيس
دوفو الفرنسيه بمدينه ايرين لكن رصاص
الجاري حول عشاء العائله الى ماتم